Rene is with us in Maryland hi Renee
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Jerry
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so my husband and I are on baby set
number two and he's decided that he
wants to open up his own dump truck
business and while I'm excited about
that I'm also nervous because the dump
truck itself is about 90 K and he's
pulled funds from our 401k to cover the
down payment so I'm a little nervous
about wines are we going to be able to
meet our goal of being debt-free by next
year and are you even going to be
wanting to be successful with the
business as well and one of them is buys
from you
and encouragement I'm confused your
husband is on baby step two trying to
get out of debt and he went and bought a
$90,000 dump truck on payments these
things don't seem to go together
yes sir is he already done this deal yes
he has so I work and he works so he was
previously working for a company and
he's going to be putting in his
paperwork to quit in two weeks so yes he
has already done the paperwork the bank
has already approved the loan he's
planning it he'll pick up the truck as
of next week and I'm sure I probably
can't convince him not to do it I tried
to convince him in the beginning to get
a cheaper truck he went down there
looking at vehicles came back with
something significantly higher and if
someone's doing to something destructive
to themselves in his way in the middle
of it I don't know how to encourage them
so I don't know how to encourage Johnny
this is a nightmare
oh this is an absolute stupid but
decision
it's a horrible decision it should not
happen it should stop immediately
there's so many things wrong with it I
can't count them all
and but there's no stopping people that
are you know bound to determinate run
their car into a wall no pun intended
but uh you know to start with buying a
$90,000 Dunc truck the break-even on
that if he were to pay cash for it doing
hauls is astronomically long it's a dumb
business decision add to that the fact
that he's financing it add to that that
he took the down payment out of the 401
K add to that he has no business sense
at all because he quit his job and he
has absolutely no customers lined up and
he's going to go broke so no I can't
really encourage him I know but Darden I
mean unless you can put duct tape around
this man and keep him out of that truck
dealership I'm gonna have trouble
encouraging you
you duct tape him to a chair maybe I
don't know I think that's kidnapping
though maybe you don't want to do that
this has to stop it's a bad idea for
about seven reasons it really does not
need to go through okay if he if he
wants to go in the dump truck business
he needs to get out of debt save some
money buy a 15 or a $20,000 truck make
that truck make money that he paid cash
for and then use the cash to make
another truck make money and then grow a
fleet of trucks but you don't go ninety
thousand dollars in debt to haul rock
and dirt well this is just a bad
business move it's a bad idea so I'm not
yelling at you I'm just scared for you
I'm scared I don't know what and I don't
you know and you're you know he's
already the you know the cows are
already out of the barn I don't know how
to get him back in he's already way down
the road on this there's no putting the
brakes on this Bubba so I don't know if
there's any way you guys can stop this
even if you lose some money and delay
this I want him to be in business I if
he wants to be in the trucking business
I wanted to be in the trucking business
I want him to live his dream but when
people live their dreams inviolate seven
principles in the process that dreams
become nightmares yeah and that's where
you're headed this is not going to end
well so please play this back for him
tonight I want him to live his dream but
this is not gonna work
and there's nothing in the mathematics
here that works so here's the deal
here's what's going through my head okay
and and I'm the problem is I do math so
here's the if you take what he gets paid
per load and how many loads he can do in
a day he can't even pay his payments in
the DC metro area he seems to think he
can I know he seems to think he can but
he's the same guy made all these other
decisions so I don't really care about
his math skills I'm telling you the DC
metro area is not that they don't you're
not hauling gold over there there's you
know they're not paying you in gold bars
to haul this stuff around this is it's
he's gonna gets laid oh I don't know
what I don't know what tell you you got
to stop him that's what I'm gonna tell
you that's what I would tell you and
then you call me some I can't just sit
here and go along with insanity and go
well it'll work this time cuz it's not
going to it's a the whole plan is a bad
plan every aspect of it please stop it
and you're attached to this guy at the
hip well there you go Dave encouraging
Dave well just start this hour off with
encouraging Davis